Transcriber: Merve Çınar
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Gerçekten hiç kimse gözükmüyormuş.
Merhaba ben Dilara. Melih Bey’den
sonra çıkmam çok iyi oldu.
Çok heyecanlıyım.
Çok rahat konuşurum normalde ama,
kalabalıkta birazcık böyle
heyecanlanıyorum.
Ama konu o kadar güzeldi.
Ve tabi ki TEDx olunca konuşmamak
mümkün değil.
Hayır demek.
Şimdi size iki hikaye anlatacağım.
Bir tanesi kendi hikayem,
bir tanesi de Simurg’un hikayesi.
Aslında ikisi birbirine
çok bağlı hikayeler.
Burada da çok genç olduğu için aslında
tam da bu konuyla ilgili anlatmak
istediklerim var.
Bizim zamanımızda
bu da çok iyi ama tam olsun.
Bizim zamanımızda şöyle bir şey vardı,
ailelerimizin arzuları ve istekleri uğruna
daha çok eğitimler devam ederdi.
Ben de Terakki’de okudum, çok sevgili
arkadaşlarım da burada Terakki’de
okuduğum zaman lise 2′den sonra
fen ya da edebiyat seçiyorduk.
O zaman babama sordum ben ne arzu
ediyorsunuz gibilerinden.
Babam da dedi ki,
″Evladım gelecek teknolojide
bilgisayarda, sen fen oku dedi.″
Çok doğru.
Çok ileri görüşlü bir insanmış.
Fakat kadın doğru kadın değil.
Ben sanattan, resimden, kitap
okumaktan hoşlanıyorum.
Edebiyat yerine oraya girdim.
Fakat bu arada hayatımız değişti.
Onun bütün isteklerine rağmen
bir anda ailem ayrıldı.
Ailem ayrıldıktan sonra kariyer için
yetişmiş bir kadın olmama rağmen bir anda
kendimi, bir anda demeyeyim, evlendim.
Çocuğum, erken yaşta çocuğum
oldu ve bütün o hayal
ettiğim hayatı geride bıraktım.
O zaman için çok zorluydu.
Herkes okurken onu istiyordum falan ama,
aslında kader bir şekilde
ağlarını örüyormuş.
Yani istediğim çok daha ara vermek
yerine önceden bunu yapıp.
Bu arada da tabii ki farklı
bir şey okuyacaktım.
Çünkü teknik üniversiteyi kazanmıştım.
Onun yerine potansiyel kursiyer oldum.
Önce ve fiilen çalıştım.
Resim yaptım, vitray yaptım,
heykele girdim.
Bütün her bir şeyi denerken hayatıma
Mehmet Kabaş girdi.
Allah rahmet eylesin.
Urartu’nun kurucusudur.
Akademideyken bana dedi ki Sen
bunlarla uğraşmayı bırak.
Sen bütün bunların bütün hepsinin bir
arada yapabileceğin mücevher yapabilirsin.
Öyle bir gözün var.
Muhakkak bunu yapman lazım.
Onun üstüne ben onun dediğini dinledim.
Fakat çarşıya girdim.
Önce Akademi'de onun eğitimini aldım.
Sonra beni Kapalıçarşı’ya yolladı
orada çalışmaya başladım.
Tam o arada her şey gene dediğim gibi
giderken bir anda değişti ve
ayrıldım.
Ayrılınca ne yapacağımı tam bilmezken
mücevher kariyerim devreye girdi.
Dükkanımı açtım.
Önce şöyle bir şey yaptım.
Kapalıçarşı’da çalışırken dediler ki
baget ve mücevher ile uğraşırken ben
dedim kendi istediklerimi
yapmak istiyorum.
Muhakkak öyle bir gözüm var o zaman.
Dalga geçtiler.
Dediler ki ″Bu seni yaptıklarını
kimse takmaz.″
″Kocaman kaldırım taşı gibi.″
O yüzden bunu yapamazsın.
Dedim ki ben dinleyeceğim.
Eğer ben takıyorsam tabii ki onlar
da takacaklar ya da beğenen muhakkak
çıkacaktır deyip öyle de oldu.
Sonra bir isim oldu, marka oldu.
Çok keyif aldım, çok mutluydum o
mutluluğun içinde hayat beni bir şekilde
daha çok tanındığım için daha
farklı bir yere gittim.
Kapalıçarşı gibi beni çok besleyen ve
bütün ustaların olduğu, bambaşka taşların,
muhabbetlerin, keyfin olduğu
bir yerden çıktım.
Belki iş olarak daha imkanlı, daha çok
para kazandım diyeyim fakat
tasarım tarafımı bitmeye başladı ve ben
için için mutsuz oldum.
Ondan sonra bunu her ne kadar öyle belli
etmesem de yavaş yavaş o tasarımı
yaparkenki aldığınız keyif
bittikten sonra
birazcık uzaklaştım.
Ondan sonra devam ederken hayat bu sefer
tesadüflerle beni daha evvelden aldığınız
küçücük Ayvacık da bir Ahmetce köyündeki
evimize getirdi.
Oraya geldiğim andan itibaren
bir şehirden ne kadar yorulduğumu anladım.
iki, hayatını değiştirmek
istediğimi fark ettim.
Mutlu değildim çünkü bence.
Bütün bunun arasında bir parantez
açmak istiyorum.
Buradaki gençlere şunu söylemek istiyorum:
Lütfen mutlu olduğunuz şeyi yapın hayatta
çünkü çocuklarınızdan, eşinizden,
sevdiğinizden, her kimden ne olursa
olsun bu kadar vakit geçirmiyorsunuz.
En çok işinizde oluyorsunuz.
Orada aldığınız eğer mutluysa hayatınız
mutlu demektir ve o mutluluk hem
yanınızdakikilere, hem ailenize
hem işinize yansıyor.
Sonra buraya gelince dedim ki ben
dönmeyeceğim, dönmeyeceğim de
bir dükkan var, bir kariyer var.
Bunlar nasıl olacak?
O kadar mutlu olduğumu istemiyordum ki.
Vazgeçtim.
Yapmayacağım dedim,
kapatacağım dükkanı.
Dükkanı falan kapattık ama bu sefer de
peki bu nasıl devam edecek bu hayat?
O arada eski eşim devreye girdi.
Dedi ki ″En iyi bildiğin şeyi yap, yedir,
içir, eğlendirir.″
Çok severim çünkü ben.
Yani masalar kurayım.
Çünkü kalabalık bir ailede büyüdüm
ve bizim en benim keyif aldığım,
hatırladığım, kendimi mutlu hissettiğim
en iyi olduğu yer uzun masadır.
O yüzden yemek yapmayı çok severim.
Misafir ağırlamayı çok severim.
Biz dört odaylı evi çevirip
misafir ağırlamaya başladım ama
gerçekten misafir ağırladım.
Yani otel gibi değil.
Masayı kuruyoruz masamda.
Politika konuşturmam, din konuşturmam,
futbol konuşturmam bunlar bitince
çünkü insanlar gerçek sohbeti yapmaya
başlıyorlar çekişmeden.
Bu arada daha evvel kalabalık ailelerde
büyüyenler biliyorlar.
Sonrasında daha
yalnızlaşmaya başladık.
Oraya geldiğinizde o masanın çevresinde
insanlar tekrardan aile olmayı, birlikte
olmayı, sohbet etmeyi, konuşmaya
başladılar ve bu öyle dilden dile yayıldı.
Orada da keyifli bir şey oldu.
Beni çok mutlu eden bir şey oldu.
Peki başına döneyim, neden
bu arada da bunu yapmaya karar
verdiğimde adı Simurg oldu.
Aslında hepsi birbirine bağlı ve
bir rüyayla başlamıştı burası.
Simurg olmasının nedeni
ben buraya gelmeden önce bugün de farkında
olmadan o yüzüğü takmışım.
En son yaptığım koleksiyonumun
adı Simurg’tu.
Simurg otuz kuş demek aslında Anka kuşu.
Bütün dünya kötülüğe doğru gitmekte iken,
kaos olduğu bir zamanda kuşlar meclisi
toplanır ve kendi aralarında derler ki
Simurg’u bulursak o bizi bu hayattan
alır, kurtarır ve bize doğruyu gösterir,
işte bizi kötülüklerden alır falan diye
hepsi oturdular ve karar
verirler, Kaf dağındaki
Simurg’u aramaya çıkarlar ve yedi
tane vadiden geçerler.
Yedi vadinin adları
arayış, aşk, idrak, ayrılık, birlik,
ölüm ve hayret.
Bütün bunları geçtikten sonra,
bu arada bunları geçerken kuşlar
yavaş yavaş azalmaya başlarlar.
Bülbül gülünü özler, geri döner.
Tavus kuşu benim tüylerim burdan
kötü etkileniyor der, vazgeçer.
Baykuş bilgeliğim vardı zaten der.
Kala kala otuz kuş kalır ve bu burada
gördükleri şudur, onları kurtaracak
hiç kimse yoktur,
sadece kendileri vardır.
Bütün o güç bizde.
O yüzden de bu Ayağa Kalk
stand up şeyi geldiğinde ilk aklıma
gelen oldu.
Kimseye ihtiyacımız yok.
Bütün güç kendi içimizde.
Ben bir Simurgum, Simursunuz.
Hepinizde bu güç, bu kuvvet var.
O yüzden de başkalarında aramayalım.
Kendi gücümüzle ayağa kalkalım.
Çok teşekkür ederim.